how is it we should measure information
in a way that applies to any
communication system you can think of
human animal or alien
well let's return to the late 19th
century where at the time we were
focused as we are today on speed and one
goal to improve speed was to design a
machine which allowed the operators to
input letters which we can think of as
primary symbols and have the Machine
automate the lower-level signaling
events such as pulses of electricity
what we can call secondary symbols and
machines can be driven by some clock
source allowing it to generate a precise
and rapid pulse stream which presumably
would run much faster than any human
hand and one great example of this was
the Bedok multiplex system and the
design was put into service in 1874 and
it built off the same conceptual ideas
we've seen in the shuttered Telegraph it
consisted of five keys which could be
played in any combination think of it as
a chord each combination would represent
a unique message with five notes each
either on or off you can play two to the
power of five or 32 different chords the
code assigned the 32 different chords to
each letter of the alphabet
with the left over used for carriage
returns newline and spaces so the
operator would literally play letters
and their machine would automatically
output a pulse stream representing the
letters
like this for letter T or like this for
letter R or like this for letter B so we
have an output signal containing various
combinations of DC impulses a signal
that accurately represents the message
typed on the teletypewriter behind the
counter the mechanical nerves of the
system change words two holes on tape
and the holes on tape two electrical
impulses speeding over the wires notice
at the lowest level this system is
exchanging either the presence or
absence of electrical current in a
sequence divided using a clock so how
fast can our internal clocks run well
the limiting speed was not the clock
then and today the speed of transmission
was physically limited by the minimum
spaces between these impulses or the
pulse rate and this problem plagued
engineers who were testing underground
submarine cables using the existing
Morse code system and it's similar to an
echo or a sustained note if one sends
dots too fast over a long undersea
circuit they will run together at the
receiving end because the symbol we
received at the far end of the circuit
will be a slightly longer smoothed out
rise and fall not an exact replica and
sending pulses too fast
results in inter symbol interference
this occurs for example when the longer
flow of a current bleeds into the next
time division and perhaps reverses a 0
to a 1 so even if we are automating the
detection of these current levels there
is a fundamental limit to how far we can
squeeze two pulses together and this is
the same problem Alice and Bob ran into
with their string communication system
which we called the maximum pluck speed
if they plucked any faster than - plucks
per second they noticed they started to
bleed together and they got confused so
this is called the symbol rate remember
a symbol can be broadly defined as the
current state of some observable signal
which persists for a fixed period of
time whether you are using fire sound
electrical current anything a signaling
event is simply a change from one state
to another so the symbol rate is the
number of signaling events which can be
squeezed together in one second